liebe kolleginnen und kollegen herzlich
willkommen in der bundespressekonferenz
wenn sich die kameraleute und fotografen
zurückziehen können wir uns alle sehen
noch einmal herzlich willkommen ihre
kolleginnen und kollegen in der
bundespressekonferenz
heute zu gast sitzt neben mir
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer und
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn um
uns zu unterrichten zum thema corona
virus und damit über gebe ich auch
direkt an herrn spahn der vielen dank
vielen dank für ihr interesse und die
gelegenheit das bundesministerium des
innern und das bundesministerium für
gesundheit haben gestern den im
pandemieplan des bundes vorgesehenen
krisenstab eingesetzt
in diesem fall zur bekämpfung des des
ausbruches mit dem kroner virus ziel ist
es die bevölkerung so gut wie möglich zu
schützen und diese epidemie so weit als
möglich einzudämmen
wir stehen seit beginn der krise im
ständigen austausch mit dem
bundesministerium des innern aber auch
mit anderen ressorts der bundesregierung
die mit helfen die ausbreitung des virus
in deutschland zu verhindern und die
deutsche bevölkerung vor den neuartigen
atemwegserkrankung zu schützen
die sind austausch institutionalisieren
wir jetzt mit diesem krisenstab das
zeigt wir nehmen den ausbruch des
choriner kona virus ernst und wir
reagieren auf die neue lage in der sich
deutschland europa und die ganze welt
befindet wir befinden uns am beginn
einer krone epidemie in deutschland
diesen satz habe ich gestern sehr
bewusst gesagt um uns alle auch auf ein
neues szenario und auf die neue
entwicklung vorzubereiten werden wir
müssen damit rechnen dass mit den
entwicklungen die wir in norditalien
aber jetzt eben auch in nordrhein
westfalen sehen sich die epidemie auch
bei uns ausbreitet bisher ist es
gelungen und sind weiterhin mit
hochdruck daran gearbeitet jede
infektion frühzeitig zu erkennen
den infizierten patienten zu isolieren
klinisch zu behandeln und alle
kontaktpersonen zu identifizieren dann
auch aufzusuchen zu testen
und eben vorsorglich in häusliche
quarantäne zu bringen die jüngste
entwicklung in nordrhein-westfalen zeigt
das gelingt moment nur unter größten
aufwand und auch nicht abschließend ein
thema ist unter anderem dass wir den
kern die erstinfektion zum beispiel in
nordrhein-westfalen anders als bei allen
anderen ausbruchs entwicklungen die wir
bis jetzt in deutschland gesehen haben
noch nicht haben ausfindig machen können
in jedem fall geht es natürlich weiter
um weiterhin darum als
ausbruchsgeschehen zu verlangsamen
einzudämmen
möglichst alle kontaktpersonen auch zu
kontaktieren und zu isolieren
zumindest in der selbstisolation zu
hause gleichwohl müssen wir uns eben
darauf einstellen dass es nicht mehr so
möglich sein wird in der zukunft die wir
das eben aus den erfahrungen der letzten
vier bis sechs wochen auch kennengelernt
haben und auch in dieser lage in dieser
neuen lage müssen wir zeigen dass wir
alles tun als bund als staat als
bundesregierung unsere bürgerinnen und
bürger bestmöglich zu schützen und genau
darum geht es eben mit der einrichtung
dieses krisenstabes
den kern des krisenstabes stellen das
bundesministerium des innern und das
bundesministerium für gesundheit
aber wir uns natürlich auch die
expertise angriff source wie etwa des
verkehrsministeriums des auswärtigen
amtes der bundespolizei oder auch
anderer beteiligter wie der deutschen
bahn
der krisenstab hat in größerer runde
gestern bereits einmal getagt und erste
beschlüsse gefasst so sollen flugreisen
aus infektions gebieten künftig
informationen über den aufenthaltsort
nach landung angeben nicht nur wenn sie
aus china einreisen sondern auch aus
südkorea japan iran und italien also
diese anordnung die ich gemeinsam mit
dem bundesminister für verkehr dann auch
treffen werde
wir wollen darüber hinaus die bahn und
busunternehmen auffordern entsprechende
informationsmaterialien
insbesondere für den reiseverkehr aus
norditalien auch zugänglich zu machen
für ihre passagiere und mitreisenden
zudem habe ich gestern in einer schalte
mit den gesundheitsministern der länder
vereinbart und diese auch gebeten ihre
landes pandemiepläne soweit noch nicht
geschehen zu aktualisieren und sich auf
ein mögliches inkraftsetzen
vorzubereiten weil wir natürlich auf
jede weitere entwicklung gut vorbereitet
sein wollen ich habe mich gestern auch
mit vertretern der ärzteschaft der
krankenkassen der krankenhäuser der
apotheker und aus der pflege getroffen
um mit ihnen gemeinsam zu erörtern wie
wir noch besser auf die jetzige
situation reagieren können wie es noch
besser gelingen kann auch alle die vor
ort in den praxen in den apotheken in
den pflegeeinrichtungen ja gefragt
werden wie gehe ich jetzt mit dieser
situation um was ist im konkreten
verdachtsfall zu tun wie kann ich mich
informieren darüber aufzuklären 170000
arztpraxen und 20.000 apotheken über
2.000 krankenhäuser 14.000
pflegeeinrichtungen tatsächlich im
informationsfluss zu erreichen ist eben
eine aufgabe den ich mit einer e mail
verschicken getan ist sondern mit der
wir uns schon seit wochen beschäftigen
und der wir haben gestern noch mal einen
entsprechenden nachdruck auch geben
wollten
wir haben uns dabei darauf geeinigt dass
es wichtig ist dass im zweifel einmal
mehr auf das virus getestet wird als
einmal zu wenig das also ist am geld
nicht scheitern darf und dass die
krankenkassen eben die entsprechenden
testen dann wenn ein arzt die für
notwendig hält auch übernehmen sollen
das ist wichtig denn in so einer
situation wie der jetzigen treibt viele
bürgerinnen und bürger die große sorge
um die jetzt damit umzugehen ist sie
haben fragen und sind unsicher und dem
können wir am besten eben dann begegnen
wenn auch vor ort in der praxis in der
apotheke im krankenhaus entsprechend
fundierte antworten gegeben werden
können und dafür ist eben auch die
informationen aller beteiligten wichtig
wir haben darüber hinaus begonnen mit
dem robert-koch-institut auch heute
erstmalig in regelmäßigen ein bis
zweitägigen abständen für sie auch
fachliche informationen im
pressegespräch zur verfügung zu stellen
über das was in den letzten wochen schon
gemacht wurde hinaus auch zur einordnung
des virus und allem was damit
zusammenhängt wir haben die
informationen auf den seiten der
bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung des robert koch institutes
und des bundesministeriums für
gesundheit
zwischenzeitlich war gestern aufgrund
der großen nachfrage einige der surfer
an der kapazitätsgrenze wir haben über
nacht die kapazitäten erweitert damit
natürlich weiterhin auch online alle
verfügbaren informationen zugänglich
sind wir haben die hotlines die
telefonnummern der länder und des bundes
ist auch dort fahren wir die kapazitäten
jetzt noch mal hoch weil wir gerade in
den letzten zwei tagen ein entsprechend
großes informationsbedürfnis bei den
bürgerinnen und bürgern feststellen
konnten und die kassenärztliche
bundesvereinigung hat zugesagt dass
unter der nummer 11 6 11 7 die er seit
dem 11 für 24 stunden auch erreichbar
ist jeden tag dass auch unter dieser
nummer die ansonsten für die
terminvergabe und im bereitschaftsdienst
zugänglich ist entsprechende
informationen abrufbar sind wir werden
darüber hinaus für reiserückkehrer aus
norditalien es wird viel urlaubs
rückreiseverkehr gerade auch in die
südlichen bundesländer geben jetzt in
den nächsten tagen aus dem skiurlaub zum
beispiel gezielt nochmal informationen
in den zeitungen im radio auch haben und
schalten um darauf hinzuweisen wie man
sich im verdachtsfall idealer weise
verhält oder auch präventiv verhält um
auch dort möglichst breit zu informieren
diese informationsoffensive ist aus
meiner sicht deswegen wichtig weil ja
beides gelingen muss dass nicht jedes
husten gleich sozusagen zu dem verdacht
auf ebola virus führt und zu einer
entsprechenden unsicheren reaktion und
gleichzeitig eine hohe aufmerksamkeit da
ist dann wenn es eben ein begründeter
verdacht es wenn es kontakt gab etwa
eben mit der norditalienischen region
oder jetzt in diesem fall auch in den
entsprechenden ortschaften im landkreis
heinsberg kontakt gab direkt oder
indirekt und dann symptome auftauchen
dass man halt dann natürlich auch sehr
bewusst den arzt oder das gesundheitsamt
anruft auch das ist übrigens wichtig
nicht ins wartezimmer setzen zu den
anderen patienten sondern idealerweise
telefonisch kontakt aufnehmen
die eigenen kontakt zu anderen erstmal
einstellen und dann eben entsprechend
über ein hausbesuch entweder des arztes
oder des gesundheitsamtes die
entsprechende tests durchführen das ist
glaube ich ein ganz ganz wichtiger punkt
ansonsten bleiben die hinweise die wir
gegeben haben zum persönlichen verhalten
im sozialen kontakt mit anderen was nies
und husten hygiene angeht was die frage
der händedesinfektion angeht was die
frage im übrigen auch weiterhin
vorsorglich eine grippeimpfung oder für
die über 60 jährigen auf einer koppel
impfung angeht die mithelfen
entsprechende andere erkrankungs bilder
zu reduzieren
das bleibt weiterhin gültig mit dem was
wir gesagt haben zwei punkte noch das
eine große thema das uns sehr
beschäftigt auch in diesem krisenstab er
wird die frage sein schutzausrüstung
masken entsprechendes material in
ausreichender zahl und größenordnung zu
haben
wir müssen feststellen was nicht
überraschend ist dass auf der ganzen
welt alle länder sich gerade natürlich
um zusätzliche beschaffung bemühen und
teil der wahrheit ist auch dass eines
der größten hersteller länder für das
endprodukt oder für zulieferprodukte
china ist und das natürlich mit der
situation in china
auch dort sich insgesamt für die
produktion folgen ergeben
deswegen ist das sicherlich ein punkt
der morgen auch für den krisenstaat noch
mal sehr hoch auf der tagesordnung ist
wie wir dort auch sicherstellen können
dass das was im land ist auch im land
bleibt erstmal eine schutzausrüstung
auch das ist ja ein thema um wie wir
zusätzlich an schutzausrüstung atmen
schutzhandschuhe und anderen kommen im
verbund mit unseren europäischen
partnern oder eben auch über nationale
beschaffung und als letzten punkt und
abschließend eine bemerkung in eigener
sache
wir haben bereits vor zwei drei monaten
entschieden das ist eine neue abteilung
geben wird im bundesministerium für
gesundheit eine abteilung für
gesundheitssicherheit weil wir eben
sowieso merken konnten in den letzten
jahren dass dieses thema wie bereiten
wir uns vor auflagen wie diese und wir
sind wir auch europäisch und
international vernetzt eine immer
größere bedeutung auch für unsere
tägliche arbeit im bundesministerium für
gesundheit bekommen hat deswegen bin ich
sehr froh dass am ersten dritten also
nächste woche der bisherige chef des
bundeswehrkrankenhauses ulm hans-ulrich
holte die führung dieser abteilung
übernehmen wird der generale arzt holte
amis tropenmediziner infektiologe und
fachmann für öffentliche gesundheit er
bringt erfahrung mit auch in der
vernetzten arbeit bei pandemien unter
anderem bei der beim schweinegrippe
ausbruch und seine expertise und eben
der aufbau dieser neuen abteilung wie
gesagt schon vor längerem geplant zeigt
sich aber gerade eben in dieser krise
wie wichtig das ist dass wir auch diese
veränderung für uns im bundesministerium
vorne ja meine damen und herren nach dem
auftreten der fälle von cholera
infektionen in europa und in deutschland
hat sich die lage deutlich verschärft
wir haben deshalb den auftrag als
verantwortliche minister das
menschenmögliche zu tun
zum schutz unserer bevölkerung ohne dass
wir den absoluten schutz versprechen
können
deshalb ist gestern diese krisenstab
eingerichtet worden
zwischen bmw und bmi aber es sind fast
alle anderen bundesministerien auch
beteiligt dieser krisenstab hat sich vor
allem mit zwei zentralen fragen die zum
einmaleins der infektions bekämpfungen
gehören zu beschäftigen
das ist einmal
die infektionsketten in deutschland zu
unterbinden
und auf der anderen seite
infektionsketten nach deutschland in den
griff zu bekommen
das sind die zwei großen aufgaben die
sich in diesen krisenstab fachlich
stellen und nach der ersten sitzung des
krisenstabs gestern kann man sagen das
ist die notwendigkeit weitere sitzungen
gibt die zuständigkeit des
innenministers ergibt sich als unseren
auftrag gefahrenabwehr für die
öffentliche sicherheit und ordnung
das heißt in diesem fall die
verkehrswege bei der einreise und zwar
aller möglichkeiten vom luftverkehr bis
zum schiffsverkehr in den blick zu
nehmen eben mit diesem general auftrag
infektionsketten nach deutschland
möglichst zurückzudrängen und
einzudämmen das ist die zuständigkeit
des innenministeriums daneben natürlich
die unterstützung aller politischen
maßnahmen wenn erforderlich durch die
bundespolizei die primäre
zuständigkeiten hat an den flughäfen an
den bahnhöfen an den häfen und natürlich
an der grenze
jens spahn hat schon darauf hingewiesen
ja ich möchte auch vorweg sagen die
definition von tier gestern ist richtig
beginn einer epidemie aber der begriff
beginn einer epidemie heißt es wird auch
eine weitere entwicklung nach oben geben
das ist in den begriff beinhaltet und es
ist auch eine jährliche klare aussage
gegenüber unserer bevölkerung weshalb
eben das menschenmögliche zum schutz
getan werden muss aber auch durch die
bevölkerung aus denjenigen angeht selbst
beim luftverkehr beim schiffsverkehr bei
grenzüberschreitenden zug und busverkehr
haben wir es beim luftverkehr schon
realisiert dass diese aussteiger karten
ausgefüllt werden und beim
schiffsverkehr wird es angeordnet du
hast das geld und wir hoffen dass morgen
beim grenzüberschreitenden zug und
busverkehr auch eine selbstverpflichtung
erfolg diese aussteiger karten
auszufüllen
das hat vor allem den sinn für den fall
des auftretens einer infektion aus einem
flugzeug aus einem zug zurückverfolgen
zu können wer war mit der infizierten
person in diesem flugzeug das ist ganz
wichtig und nicht jetzt nur symbol
aktion sondern für die infektions
bekämpfung für das unterbrechen der
infektionsketten unverzichtbar da sind
wir völlig einig wir werden sofort haben
wir die länder gebeten bei der
zuwanderung bei den asylbewerbern
primär untersuchungen durchzuführen
geeignete tests durchzuführen um eine
mögliche corona infektion frühzeitig zu
erkennen
wir haben im monat etwa 10.000
zuwanderer nach deutschland und ein
erheblicher teil dieser menschen kommt
über länder die man heute als
vorbelastet bezeichnen muss als
afghanistans pakistans iran irak über
diese route türkei nach über den
westbalkan meistens nach deutschland und
wir müssen natürlich alles tun weil
diese personen sich vor allem über
problemländer bewegen dass wir
frühzeitig durch untersuchungen
feststellen ob eine erkrankung gegeben
ist
wir das innenministerium wird sich im
weiteren mit der frage beschäftigen
gemeinsam mit den bundesländern ob in
diesem fall eine möglicherweise bei
einem weiteren ansteigen der infektionen
auch weitere maßnahmen notwendig sind
etwa einer gemeinsamen unterbringung von
erkrankten asylbewerbern
ich darf sie darauf hinweisen dass die
dublin überstellungen von und nach
italien schon bis auf weiteres
ausgesetzt sind aus diesem grunde
begrüße auch sehr die entscheidung der
italienischen regierung wenn sie den
zutrifft was nicht gelesen habe dass sie
passagiere von schiffen mit zuwanderern
in quarantäne halten um sicherzugehen
dass über diesen weg nicht infektionen
ins land kommen
wir haben beide die absicht das morgen
bei der zweiten sitzung des krisenstabes
der krisenstab sich mit vielen aber vor
allem auch mit der frage beschäftigt wie
können wir die infektionsketten nach
deutschland die übertragung noch weiter
zurückdrängen oder eindämmen
da spielt dann die frage eine rolle
großveranstaltung mit beachtlicher
internationaler beteiligung und ähnliche
dinge
die sollen morgen fachlich durchleuchtet
werden
ich möchte da heute auch gar nichts
ankündigen sondern es geht uns darum
dass wir fachlich diese dinge
aufarbeiten und immer abrufen was bringt
uns durch konkrete schritte und
maßnahmen in der verbreitung der
infektion wirklich voran
wir müssen vermeiden aktionismus der in
der praxis nichts bewirkt zum schutz der
menschen und umgekehrt müssen wir
maßnahmen die uns wirklich weiterbringen
bei der unterbrechung der
infektionskette aber auch angehen selbst
dann wenn sie nicht ganz einfach zu
vermitteln sein können aber wie gesagt
er soll sich mal in der krisenstab
vor allem mit dieser frage detaillierter
befassen weil ich habe in meiner zeit
als gesundheitsminister und als
landwirtschaftsminister bei der
tiergesundheit und bei der roman
gesundheit
etliche solcher fälle erlebt jetzt ich
weiß was du dort zurzeit zu schultern
hast und du hast jede unterstützung
und dann kommen wir zu ihren fragen ich
habe schon eine liste vor mir die erste
frage kommt von herrn cent ivanyi
ersparen wenn man in die nationalen
pandemiepläne schaut die ja nicht also
aktuell sind aber egal man sich anschaut
dann stehen relativ am anfang in einigen
sehr detaillierte zahlen drin von
welchen krankheitsarten man ausgehen
muss von welchen rat man ausgehen muss
dem patienten die dann möglicherweise
ins krankenhaus müssen die vier
todesfälle es gibt und davon ausgehend
sind dann die pläne entwickelt gibt es
solche detaillierten pläne und solche
betätigten annahmen jetzt auch schon und
daran schließt sich die frage an weiß
man eigentlich genau wie viele betten
krankenhäuser vorhalten die dann im
zweifel für komapatienten so
isolierstation für komapatienten
geeignet sind oder die kurzfristig
sozusagen eingerichtet werden können sie
hatten ja gestern gesagt ist es gibt so
eine zahl bei 47 bei den hochrisiko
patienten die jetzt aber sozusagen für
diesen fall jetzt nicht abwehren aber
gibt es solche zahlen und kann man die
irgendwie in deckung bringen oder vielen
betten also zum ersten das ist nun mal
wichtiger morgen schon wieder ihren
colas wir hätten nur an die 60
entsprechend isoliert
wetten dass ist für hochsicherheits
isolierung das ist nicht das was
notwendig ist für das corona virus das
muss man unterscheiden
übrigens bei den mit den sind um die um
die 50 die wir haben haben wir mehr als
die usa und den rest europas also mehr
die usa und mehr als der rest europas
zusammen
auch um das einzuordnen aber ist
ausdrücklich nicht das was wir brauchen
für das krone virus sondern für das
corona virus jetzt eben nach der
erkenntnislage heute auch für die
klinische behandlung und isolierung
sozusagen die reguläre intensivstation
und die reguläre isolierung wie sie
nicht nur in universitätskliniken
möglich ist und nicht nur in kliniken
der maximalversorgung und sondern auch
in vielen anderen kliniken eben mit
intensivstationen ist tatsächlich das
was notwendig ist und wovon es ja dann
auch deutlich mehr kapazitäten in
deutschland gibt wenn sie danach fragen
wie großen wäre ein möglicher bedarf
kann das natürlich tag heute keiner
wirklich sagen was wir gerade machen ist
dass wir den pandemieplan der ja ein
influenza pandemieplan ist und übrigens
es geht nicht um die saisonale influenza
dabei der influenza pandemieplan
adressiert so themen wie die
schweinegrippe die wir im vor zehn
jahren hatten dass der aktualisiert wird
und auf corona virus angepasst wird das
ist in der finalisierung in diesen tagen
da es aber in beiden fällen im einer
atemwegserkrankung geht mit zumindest
einem vergleichbaren symptomatiken ist
ja eben auch relativ leicht adaptierbar
und der vorteil ist eben das und
deswegen habe ich ja die länder dazu
aufgefordert ist eben auch entsprechend
an landes pandemiepläne schon gibt und
der teil ist übrigens wichtig auch
krankenhäuser pflegeeinrichtungen
rettungsdienste und unternehmen sind
nach der pandemie planung von bund und
ländern aufgefordert
schon seit acht jahren pandemiepläne zu
haben also jedes krankenhaus jede
pflegeeinrichtung sollte über einen
pandemieplan verfügen was in der
jeweiligen situation in der jeweiligen
einrichtung zu tun ist und auch hier
habe ich gebeten gestern im gespräch mit
den verbänden auch dort allemal weiter
zu sensibilisieren auch krankenhäuser
und pflegeeinrichtungen rettungsdienste
tatsächlich soweit noch nicht geschehen
ich zittere viele haben sich schon auch
damit beschäftigt aber die die es eben
nicht haben auch dafür zu
sensibilisieren was die zahlen angeht
ist das sehr sehr schwer das zu zu
skalieren
übrigens auch in der frage wie es
tatsächlich insgesamt der verlauf des
videos ich möchte gerne in der nächsten
woche auch für sie hier als angebot
machen dass wir noch mal
auch mit fachleuten wissenschaftlern
über das virus hier sobald die
bundespressekonferenz daran interesse
hat sehr ausführlich einfach mal
informieren was wir wissen über über die
frage was wie ist der verlauf die
symptomatik erkenntnis heute ist ja 80
prozent der infizierten haben sehr milde
verläufe oder gar keine symptomatik aber
wir haben eben dann an die 20 prozent us
schwerere dann ein noch kleinerer
prozent teil schwerste verläufe gibt und
dann ist die frage auch wie hoch ist die
sterblichkeitsrate auch das ist sehr
schwer zu sagen weil wir ja nur
erfahrungen aus anderen ländern da haben
und in china ist es nicht mehr so schon
lange nicht mehr so dass jede infektion
in die statistik geht es geht nur die in
die statistik ein
nach einer änderung die tatsächlich
behandelt werden das führt natürlich
dazu wenn sozusagen die zahl der
tatsächlichen infektion statistisch
nicht so groß ist wie es eigentlich ist
und das setzen sie eine relation zu den
todesfällen dass das sozusagen zu einer
über skalierung führen kann und deswegen
ist es aus sicht heute eben sehr sehr
schwer abschließend einzuordnen wie es
mit schwersten verlaufen und tödlichen
verläufen in relation zum gesamt
infektionsgeschehen er ausschaut aber
über diese fragen wie gesagt würde ich
sie gerne noch mal auch zusammen etwa
mit behandelnden informieren in der
nächsten woche die zahl der
intensivstation und betten die wir haben
es sind einige tausend die kann ich
ihnen aus dem kopf jetzt nichts sagen
die liefer ich aber gerne nach die
nächste frage hat die kollegen von
spiegel online
ich wollte einmal fragen und zwar selber
gar nicht schon gesagt dass 80 prozent
der fälle entweder sehr mild verlaufen
oder gar keine symptome zeigen wie hoch
schätzen sie denn die dunkelziffer in
deutschland schon ein und andererseits
wollte
inwieweit werden jetzt auch schon also
könnte es sein dass im katastrophenfall
auch die bundeswehr im inland eingesetzt
wird
mir ist nicht bekannt dass ich für
verteidigung zuständig bin ich glaube
das szenario sehe ich nicht auch nicht
die notwendigkeit das können wir schon
mit unseren kräften schultern
ich bin nur noch mal aus meiner sicht
und erfahrung ich habe das glaube ich
sechs oder sieben mal durchlaufen
solche schwierigen prozesse ich glaube
man ist immer gut beraten ein stück mehr
an schutz und prävention zu tun als
gerade an wissenschaftlicher erkenntnis
vorhanden ist so dass ich immer alles
richtig gewesen wenn etwas von
überflüssig ist weil man mehr getan hat
als notwendig dann umso besser für die
menschen aber ich neige man dazu ein
stück mehr an schutz für die menschen zu
machen als uns wissenschaftler die ich
nicht kritisiere mit ihren
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse
vermitteln arbeitskraft der stimmen wir
überein meint wir sind übereinstimmung
dass
denn erst mit denen ich spreche
eigentlich total zu 100 prozent da und
dort wissen wir auch noch zu wenig
belastbares das muss man bitte in
rechnung stellt was ein übertragungsweg
die inkubationszeit die verläufe und so
weiter das ist alles richtigen auch
bisher erfahrung was gesagt wurde vom
netz aber es gibt auch viele viele erste
sagen das wissen ist noch zu schmal
zum einen das aufgreifen
das stimmte total über einem zweifel die
vorsichtige herangehensweise übrigens
auch der schutz der bevölkerung geht vor
auch im vergleich zu anderen erwägungen
ökonomischen oder anderen erwägungen ist
am ende immer eine frage von
verhältnismäßigkeit und abwägung aber
wir haben zum ersten mal um das
einzuordnen in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik in der größenordnung von
über 120 bürgerinnen und bürgern eine
zentrale unterbringung veranlasst eine
quarantäne
bei der repatriierung aus wo anders als
vorher so als maßnahme noch nicht
gegeben weil wir sie eben für notwendig
gehalten haben und ich weiß noch dass
einige gesagt haben muss das sein
ist das denn angemessen und wir haben
zum damaligen zeitpunkt und ich würde
heute wieder so entscheiden gesagt ja es
ist angemessen weil wir eben noch nicht
abschließend etwas über das virus wissen
das ist der entscheidende punkt warum
die unsicherheit da ist und warum wir im
zweifel eben für die sicherheit optieren
ist dass wir abschließende erkenntnisse
zu dem was das virus im menschen macht
und die frage eben tatsächlich die
verhältnisse und die relationen sind
noch nicht haben wir haben immer
tagesaktuell erkenntnisse die wahrheit
ist aber eben auch wir haben heute
deutlich mehr wissen als vor vier wochen
und deswegen ist natürlich der ansatz
der ja auch in der pandemieplanung und
in der frage internationaler standard
ist wie gehen wir mit einer solchen lage
um vor allem auch der so lange als eben
möglich daran arbeiten wir jeden tag und
jetzt gemeinsam auch in dem krisenstab
noch mal institutionalisiert einzudämmen
zu verlangsamen infektionskette zu
unterbrechen
weil wenn sie nach vier wochen mehr
wissen hier können sie ihm anders damit
umgehen als wir noch vor vier wochen
hätten damit umgehen können und
bestimmte dinge müssen wir haben heute
schon die man damals nicht wissen eben
bei weitem noch nicht alles über das
virus und auch das muss man sagen was
die frage angeht übrigens zudem
intensivbetten wollte ich noch
hinzufügen heads and one i es ist ja
jederzeit möglich und das ist auch
vorgesehen jetzt mal in der weiteren
entwicklung auch provisorisch intensiv
und isoliere einheiten dann weiter zu
bilden aus regulären stationen also es
ist dann meine freiheit der
entsprechende maßnahmen die man da
trifft aber man kann natürlich auch
isolier einheiten dann immer weiter die
zahl erhöhen auch durch entsprechende
provisorische maßnahmen die man ergreift
und auch dafür gibt es dann dafür ist ja
die pandemieplanung auch auch die häuser
bezogen am ende mit mit da oder das
festlegen von schwerpunkt krankenhäusern
in einer region und anderes mehr das ist
genau teil der landes pandemieplanung
und der pandemieplanung der häuser die
frage der dunkelziffer wie sie es
genannt habe also möglicher nicht
erkannter infektionen hier in
deutschland in europa ich kann ihnen die
zahl ich kann hier keine jetzt alle hier
wild spekulieren das kann halt keiner
sagen was wir sicherstellen wollen ist
das eine mögliche infektion früher ist
möglich erkannt wird und das ist ja die
herausforderung die wir gerade in
heinsberg haben
das ist relativ spät erkannt wurde und
die betroffenen und das ist kein vorwurf
in der beschreibung weil sie wussten ja
nicht dass sie infiziert sind eben noch
sehr rege am sozialen leben und karneval
war halt auch gerade in der region
teilgenommen haben und deswegen ist es
ihm wichtig früh ist möglich eine
mögliche infektion festzustellen
und deswegen ist es mir so wichtig dass
diese unsicherheit in den praxen
verschwindet wann kann ich eigentlich
testen und wann nicht
und jetzt ein von der kasse bezahlt oder
nicht mir ist sehr sehr wichtig dass die
botschaft die vor zwei drei wochen schon
mal gesetzt wurde wir jetzt nochmal
setzen und eben auch über die
kassenärztlichen vereinigung setzen mit
unterstützung der kassen wenn der arzt
entscheidet das in der situation wegen
verdacht und oder symptomatik eine
testung notwendig ist dann muss eben
auch sie entsprechend von den kassen
getragen werden und wenn dafür eine
rechtsänderung nötig seien
sollte weil irgendwo irgend jemanden das
anders sieht als wir dann ändern wir das
recht auf bin von wenigen tagen ich
jedenfalls möchte im zweifel mehr tests
als nötig als zu wenig ich möchte nicht
ganz unter den tisch fallen lassen was
ich für sehr positiv betrachtet die
tatsache dass viele etliche große
deutsche unternehmen ihre mitarbeiter
gewandt haben vor reisen in diese
problemregionen ich finde es ein sehr
verantwortliches verhalten auch im sinne
von eigenen verantwortung aber es zeigt
auch dass auch unternehmen konzerne
sagen der gesundheitsschutz geht uns vor
für unseren wirtschaftlichen interessen
denn sie erkennen genau wenn man die
dinge nicht beherrscht dann wird es für
die wirtschaft noch viel dramatischer
und deshalb ist ein geordnetes vorgehen
da ganz ganz wichtig auch im
wirtschaftlichen interesse aber im
zweifel muss immer der gesundheitsschutz
vor kommerziellen interessen stehen die
nächste frage der kollege zwei reihen
dahinter
danke jensen art in der
spanischsprachigen morgen beim facharzt
der sich beschwerte dass er seiner
meinung nach viel zu wenig informationen
erhalten hatte sagt er würde auch gerne
wüsste gar nicht wie sich patienten
gegenüber verhält die symptome haben
dann würde auch gerne so einen test
machen
er wurde dann alles informiert nur
allgemein beziehen mediziner hausärzte
und ist so ein test überhaupt für jeden
machbar und die zweite frage wie sind
sie mit der medialen berichterstattung
zu frieden finden sie gut dass das ein
breites thema essen haben sie angst habe
ich auch panik geschürt werden vielen
dank
zum einen was die information der
ärzteschaft angeht
es gibt fachinformationen seitens des
robert-koch-institutes eben auch gezielt
an die ärzteschaft und natürlich habe
ich schon auch vor längerem sowohl die
bundesärztekammer wie die
kassenärztliche bundesvereinigung
gebeten weil ich habe ja nicht die
verteiler sozusagen direkt im
ministerium um mitzuhelfen das haben sie
auch nicht nur zugesichert auch noch
gemacht eben alle ärztin und er
in deutschland regelmäßig auch zu
informieren aber die wahrheit ist eben
auch wenn sie eine information 170.000
arzt und zahnarztpraxen an 20.000
apotheken ein zweieinhalbtausend
krankenhäusern 14.000
pflegeeinrichtungen und 100.000
beschäftigte im gesundheitswesen bringen
wollen dann glaube ich ist es logisch
dass wir das sehr kontinuierlich machen
würden dass es nicht einmal erreicht so
eine info sozusagen aus zu schicken
sondern wir sehr regelmäßig und auch das
haben wir gestern noch mal vereinbart
über alle kanäle die auch die
institutionen haben die verbände die
körperschaften immer wieder eine
informieren müssen
wir haben auch noch mal entsprechend
informationsmaterialien
es mag banal klingen aber macht einen
unterschied poster die ausgehängt werden
können und sollen in den praxen in den
apotheken informationsflyer und anderes
mehr
eben erarbeitet und stellen das zur
verfügung aber sie haben schon recht ich
stelle auch fest dass wir im grunde
jeden tag aufs neue immer wieder dieses
bewusstsein und dieses angebot zu
informationen schaffen müssen und auch
einladen müssen dazu sich zu informieren
auch der teil
er glaube ich gehört da dazu und zwar
die allgemeinbevölkerung auf den
entsprechenden ist es noch mal auch
online verfügbaren informationen bei
google müssen wir einmal und da hab ich
google suche
seiten im internet ist auch wichtig dass
die informationen verfügbar sind die
fachliche informationen sind und dann
sind wir im zweifel auch bei dem was sie
mit der zweiten frage angesprochen haben
das ist ja auch die herausforderung von
der ich stehe und auch in den letzten
wochen stehe auch miteinander die
balance zu schaffen
aufmerksam zu machen auf die
ernsthaftigkeit der situation auf das
was passieren kann was sich entwickeln
kann was wir vom ersten tag natürlich
mit im blick hatten über die
entschiedenheit auch mit der wir
maßnahmen ergreifen und gleichzeitig die
dinge auch so anzugehen dass das ja
nicht über reaktionen entstehen oder
über unsicherheit noch zusätzlich durch
das verhalten oder die kommunikation
entsteht wenn ich in einem nebensatz
sage dass die arzneimittel
wirkstoffproduktion eben auch
zusammenhängt mit china dann musste ich
feststellen dass zwei stunden später
mehr ärzte und apotheker berichten dass
die patienten der wahl gesagt haben wir
wollen auf vorrat schon mal noch zwei
rezepte haben was ich total
nachvollziehen kann
aber sie sehen eben wie jeder nebensatz
sofort nachvollziehbarer weise zu einer
reaktion führt so und und um diese
balance geht es mir jedenfalls in der in
der kommunikation immer lage angemessen
immer verhältnismäßig immer auf dem
stand des wissens dass wir zur stunde in
diesen minuten haben zu informieren und
gleichzeitig kann ich sie medien seit
ich halt immer nur bitten diesen weg
dann im rahmen aller kritischer
berichterstattung die immer notwendig
ist dann eben auch mit zu gehen da haben
wir auch alle gemeinsam der
verantwortung vor allem war fast die
frage der sachlichen informationen über
das virus mögliche vorbeugung und
verhaltensweisen angehen kurzer zusatz
zur ersten frage wie sieht so ein test
ab ist es eine urin test eine
blutabnahme
der test ist eine speichelprobe ein
abstrich der kann von jedem arzt dann
eingeschickt worden wir haben eine
situation die haben gar nicht so viele
länder auf der welt schon erreicht
in dieser frage das nämlich alle oder
fast alle labore die wir in deutschland
haben die auch für die reguläre
versorgung kassen herzlich da sind also
die anderen testung machen wenn sie beim
arzt sich auf was auch immer testen
lassen dass diese labore mittlerweile
fast alle über die kapazität verfügen
auch diese tests durchführen zu können
am anfang war es ja ein zwei uni
kliniken in ganz deutschland nur den
test machen konnten
mittlerweile geht das sehr
flächendeckend eben auch bei fast allen
laboren die wir sowieso in der regulären
versorgung haben und das ist eine lage
die haben so auch noch gar nicht so
viele länder erreicht dass es in dem
umfang auch test kapazitäten gibt also
derart schickt ein und spricht dann von
dem labor
die rückmeldung die nächste frage gehen
wir zurück
sascha meyer von dpa herr seehofer eine
kleine nachfrage zum
grenzüberschreitenden bus und
bahnverkehr sprachen sie von einer
selbstverpflichtung können sie das noch
mehr kleider klären wer sich da selbst
verpflichten soll und was genau kommt da
auf die fahrgäste zu und zum zweiten an
den sportminister gefragt es gibt ja
jetzt in verschiedenen sportarten schon
diskussionen bestimmte veranstaltungen
ohne publikum zu machen oder zu
verschieben
wie sehen sie diese debatten halten sie
das für geboten vielleicht auch darüber
nachzudenken in der fußball bundesliga
spiele ohne publikum im einzelfall zu
erwägen und es wird ja sogar auch schon
diskutiert oder über olympia in tokio
wie sehen sie da möglicherweise
zusammenhänge zum corona virus das ist
zur ersten frage da geht es noch mal um
den komplex aussteiger karten wer war in
dem zug
wir waren dem flugzeug werfen in dem
schiff oder wer war in den bus das hat
vor allem den sinn
im falle einer infektion zurückverfolgen
zu können wer war mit dieser person in
kontakt weil im gleichen flugzeug
gezeigt
das ist das im luftverkehr ist es
möglich da gibt es die gesetzliche
grundlage
im schiffsverkehr auch habe ich jetzt
heute gelernt da wird das angeordnet
oder
ist bereits angeordnet und im bahn- und
busverkehr haben wir keine unmittelbare
rechtsgrundlage deshalb hat man im
krisenstaat gesagt die bahn und die
privaten busunternehmen soll morgen in
krisenstab sagen ob sie diese
aufforderung folgen
das ist die situation die
infektionskette im falle des falles
unterbrechen zu können
eine andere frage ist gibt es
notwendigkeiten den transport der
infektion in die bundesrepublik
deutschland an sich zu vermeiden ein
ganz anderer ansatz wo ich immer dachte
als in meiner funktion gefahrenabwehr
für die öffentliche sicherheit dass sie
gesundheitlich in sicherheit
ob so was notwendig ist um so was sinn
macht und darüber muss man sich auch im
krisenstaat beschäftigen genauso wie mit
großveranstaltungen wobei natürlich bei
großveranstaltungen auch wider abgewogen
werden muss nehmen da viele leute teil
aus krisengebieten zb wir beide darum
gebeten dass sich der krisenstab morgen
mal mit der internationalen
tourismusbörse die glaube ich nächste
woche in berlin stattfindet beschäftigt
da stoßen sich ja gesundheitsschutz und
wirtschaftliche interessen stark im raum
man muss das beurteilen die für leute
kommen aus china und aus anderen ländern
die belastet sind und muss uns
politikern dann eine empfehlung geben
dafür haben wir den krisenstaat mit all
den fachleuten und man muss es so wie
entspannt sagte immer mit der
notwendigen balance diskutieren
um auch wirklich mehr wert sind effekte
zu generieren wir haben gar nichts davon
wenn wir wunderbaren aktionismus an tag
legen aber für die den schutz der
bevölkerung nichts erreichen dass das
hält mal zwei drei tage und dann kommt
die wahrheit an die oberfläche wir
müssen immer schauen in der
güterabwägung was bringt uns im sinne
dieser beiden fragen unterbrechung der
infektionskette vermeidung der infektion
beim transport in unser land wirklich
weiter das muss man und alles was man an
möglichen beschränkungen diskutiert muss
natürlich abgestimmt sein in europa muss
abgestimmt sein mit anderen betroffenen
länder
wenn sie sagen aus kinder darf keine
maschine mehr in deutschland landen
dann hilft es nichts wenn die maschine
in wien landet und die leute dann
weiterfahren nach deutschland verstehen
sie jetzt muss schon miteinander gemacht
werden
italiener landen halt dann in münchen
und nicht in mailand
die menschen kennen schon die wege und
deshalb muss man sowieso immer
koordinieren aufeinander abstimmen
damit es wirkung hat wenn man so etwas
ins auge fasst das muss mir auch wieder
mit den flexiblen sehr genau und
beurteilen was bringt welche maßnahmen
es zum beispiel das war sehr oft
vertreten wird grenzen dicht
das heißt jetzt überhaupt niemand mehr
raus und rein wer soll das kontrollieren
noch was geht die kontrolle nach einem
ergebnis nach augenschein
oder machen wir bei jedem test was ich
für objektiv nicht wirklich alte also
man muss immer auch nicht nur die
grundförderung aufstellen sondern auch
wie man die konsequenzen mitbedenken und
ich möchte nicht wir beide das muss man
verurteilen möchten maßnahmen die in der
praxis dann einfach objektiv uns nicht
weiterführen andererseits hat die
bevölkerung anspruch darauf dass wir uns
mit diesen fragen ernstlich
auseinandersetzen mit
großveranstaltungen und da ist meine
prämisse mehr groß veranstaltet und
gesichtspunkt wo sie besonders viele
menschen tummeln aus krisengebieten aus
belasteten ländern
das muss man anders beurteilen also in
der fc ingolstadt ging unter heftigen
spielt das anders
wenn ich darf nur ganz kurz das eine ist
noch zusätzlich zu den maßnahmen in den
fliegern in zügen ist für austeilen von
flyern proaktiv insbesondere jetzt eben
richtung von und nach norditalien
zusätzlich zu den aussteiger karten
insbesondere bei den flugzeugen
das zweite ist was ich wichtig finde bei
jeder maßnahme ins wort wenn es um
unterbrechungen von reisen geht oder die
frage was ist mit abriegeln
jetzt hat auch eine folge für die
medizinische versorgung dental darf man
nicht unterschätzen immer dann wenn sie
irgendwas abregeln der schweizer kollege
zum beispiel beschrieben in rom beim
treffen vorgestern dass das italienische
die italienische schweiz das
gesundheitswesen der italienischen
schweiz ist sehr auf die täglichen
pendler aus italien angewiesen
das heißt wenn er die grenze schließen
würde hätte er ein echtes
versorgungsproblem medizinisch und
deswegen hat jede maßnahme die mehr
greift sogar auch für die kenterung wie
gesagt wirtschaftliche fragen auch für
die versorgung folgen und das dritte nur
ergänzend ich teile alles was horst
seehofer zu den großveranstaltungen
gesagt hat findet aber immer noch
wichtig den hinweis zu geben dass die
entscheidung über die großveranstaltung
ja oder nein am ende eine von länder-
und kommunalen behörden ist nach dem
infektionsschutzgesetz wir können
unterstützend dabei tätig sein mit auch
hinweisen auf kriterien teilnehmerkreis
lokalität lokale zusammenhänge in
heinsberg wird man dinge im moment
anders beurteilen als in lübeck was
bestimmte veranstaltungen angeht das ist
auch so wir können kriterien mithelfen
zu entwickeln entscheiden müssen die
behörden vor ort noch einmal nachgefragt
herr seehofer fc ingolstadt in ehren
aber die debatte um olympia ist das
jetzt aus ihrer sicht völlig verfrüht
ja das ist fahrrad hin wenn sie
stattfindet die olympiade juli/august
jetzt wird man bei ab wie sich die
nächsten wochen und monaten beging
ich glaube aus meiner sicht besteht
jetzt als sportminister noch keine
entscheidung
die nächste frage der kollege drei
reihen dahinter vom stern ich hab es war
eine frage zu den kompetenzen und zwar
erspart hat dass ihr freund schon
angedeutet dass vieles die länder
entscheiden müssen was können sie denn
als grund überhaupt machen in dieser
situation ja ja doch vieles den ländern
obliegt bei der bekämpfung von seuchen
und weil er seehofer der hat er das auch
schon angesprochen er war ja mal
landwirtschaftsminister und
gesundheitsminister war viele vorfälle
hatte und eine seiner klagen war wohl
damals über das man eigentlich nicht
viel machen könnte wenn das nicht
hinkriegen
also können sie hier viel sagen und die
länder kriegen es dann doch nicht hin
oder wie sehen sie das
weil es jetzt schon beide fragen in
einem also zum einen ja sie haben recht
es gibt im infektionsschutzgesetz
angelegt die notwendigkeit föderalen
miteinanders und auch das mit den
kommunen vor ort den kreis
gesundheitsamt anja insbesondere den
städtischen ich darf sagen dass das sehr
sehr gut und sehr vertrauensvoll
funktioniert wie gesagt hatte gestern
eine schalte die gesundheitsminister der
länder kommen nächsten mittwoch auch
unter anderem nicht nur aber auch
insbesondere um das thema krone und
aktuelle lage wenn dann dazu erörtern
ich bin da sehr dankbar für die gute
zusammenarbeit was kann der bund formal
wir habe das robert-koch-institut dass
wir die frage der empfehlung und der des
rahmens auch was ist angemessen
neben den rahmen setzt auch für die
entscheidung der behörden vor ort sie
sind daran nicht zwingend gebunden aber
sie orientieren sich nahezu alle auch
daran weil es ja auch die frage der
verhältnismäßigkeit sich daraus ableitet
die anordnung zum reiseverkehr die horst
seehofer angesprochen hat die treffen
trifft der bund entweder wir mit dem
verkehrsministerium und oder dem
innenministerium zusammen die frage von
reisewarnungen das auswärtige amt ist
dort auf bundesebene involviert und
viele viele andere ressorts mit
unterschiedlichen aspekten auch insofern
gibt es im bereich wo der bund zuständig
ist aber immer dann wenn es zu konkreten
entscheidungen kommt großveranstaltung
ja oder nein
wie ist die anordnung für die einzelne
person in der einzelnen lage was
quarantäne unterbringung isolation
angeht
die frage wie es mit schulen
kindergärten
öffentlichen einrichtungen das sind
entscheidungen der kommunen vor ort
ich habe mir gleichwohl ich glaube wie
horst seehofer dann auch schon mehrfach
in seinem leben vorgenommen
tatsächlich auch schlüssel zu ziehen und
dann noch mal mit den ländern darüber zu
reden wenn wir die lage hinter uns haben
an welchen stellen es möglicherweise
auch eine anpassung im
infektionsschutzgesetz braucht und
übrigens auch im gesetz für die
internationalen gesundheitsvorschriften
und vor allem wo wir auch öfter üben
müssen
das glaubt die lehre kann ich heute
schon ziehen ja wir haben pandemiepläne
und ja wir haben abläufe aber ich habe
den eindruck wir üben sie nicht oft
genug in diesem land das gilt vor ort
das gilt aber auch darüber hinaus und
das ist in jedem fall eine lehrerin
ergänzen die sagte eingangs die lage ist
ernst
und was die bevölkerung in einer solchen
lage überhaupt nicht verstehen wurde
obwohl ich selber oft erlebt habe sind
die zuständigkeit diskussionen und
deshalb wenn die zuständigen die dinge
erfüllen die wir fachlich für
erforderlich halten ist es gut wenn sie
es nicht dafür muss man dies auch
öffentlich markiert wer fachlich geboten
es dann nicht vollzieht übernimmt auch
die verantwortung
ich sage das weil dafür jetzt die lage
einfach zu ernst ist um unseren großen
tagelangen wöchentlichen zuständigkeits
diskussionen zu erschöpfen
wenn es so ist wir können nur sagen und
ihren jene großveranstaltung unternehmen
viele chinesen oder die und jenen teil
und deshalb würden wir es für geboten
halten sie nicht durchzuführen
wenn dann ein land sagt wir fühlen uns
trotzdem durch
dann sind auch die verantwortlichkeiten
klar ich habe heute noch mal gebeten
auch für den morgigen krisenstab einfach
die dinge die aus unserer sicht
innenministerium und
gesundheitsministerium erforderlich sind
wünschenswert sind auch zu benennen und
nicht von vornherein schon sagen wir
können die erst dann benennen wenn
diejenigen die dafür zuständig sind es
auch
wir machen so kommen wir nicht weiter
und ich glaube ist ganz überwiegend auf
das verständnis dafür da weil die länder
hat die ernsthaftigkeit der situation
genauso einschätzen die nächste frage
hat herr dave seehofer noch mal ganz
konkret gefragt ist noch nicht ganz klar
welche handhabe eigentlich der staat
jetzt gegenüber person hat die infiziert
sind bzw unter verdacht stehen und dann
aber sich den weisungen nicht folgen
würden also beispielsweise wenn wenn
menschen unter quarantäne gestellt
werden und die das aber nicht wollen ist
das ist das sozusagen sind die
verpflichtet den folge zu leisten und
was macht man mit solchen personen
eigentlich bei bisher war das ja alles
schien mir soweit er einvernehmlich zu
geschehen also leute sind dann erstmal
da geblieben oder auf dem
kreuzfahrtschiff erst mal brav geblieben
und so aber wenn das jetzt weiter um
sich greift ja werden ja einige menschen
vielleicht auch nicht mehr freiwillig
machen
bei uns ist immer das polizeirecht
einschläge in meinem bereich die
bundespolizei kann einen infektionsfall
an einer grenze zurückweisen
das gibt es allgemeine polizeirecht her
das infektionsschutzgesetz und liegt ein
bundesgesundheitsminister ist ein
modernes gesetz
wer sich das bundesgesetz jetzt haben
wir ein modernes infektionsschutzgesetz
und ich finde es bietet auch eine ganze
palette von möglichkeiten
es bietet sehr viele möglichkeiten
tatsächlich auch der
freiheitseinschränkung weil es ja hier
um eine güterabwägung geht nämlich die
freiheit des einzelnen gegenüber der
sicherheit der gesamtbevölkerung und
diese abwägung macht es tatsächlich
möglich
und das ist ja auch das was passiert ist
mit der zentralen unterbringung zum
beispiel oder der häuslichen quarantäne
wenn es heißt häusliche quarantäne dann
denkt man manchmal immer hier bleiben
freiwillig zu hause das ist eine
behördliche anweisung zu hause zu
bleiben
die von den gesundheitsämtern auch
kontrolliert wird
die frage veranstaltungen abzusagen die
frage schulen bäder öffentliche
einrichtungen zu schließen
die frage ja auch für für gruppen oder
sonstwie was anzuordnen sind alles
freiheits einschränkungen die das
infektionsschutzgesetz möglich macht
natürlich ist es besser wenn es
freiwillig erfolgt und aus eigener
einsicht aber das sind so gesehen auch
polizei rechtliche maßnahmen die mit
zwang im fall der fälle durchgesetzt
werden könnten
und aus meiner sicht im fall der fälle
auch durchgesetzt werden müssten
ich habe ich am anfang sehr viel
unverständnis in westlichen ländern noch
bei uns wie die chinesischen sie würden
mit solchen fällen umgegangen sind
würden sie im nachhinein sagen dass die
adäquat darauf reagiert haben nicht wie
zum beispiel eine ganze stadt abgesperrt
haben man also es gibt ja mehrere
aspekte wenn man es jetzt mal von der
infektionsgeschehen her sieht hat das
eine wirkung gehabt das lässt sich nicht
bestreiten
das infektionsgeschehen einzudämmen zu
reduzieren
an der an der stelle es hat aber
natürlich auch folgen offenkundig für
die versorgung der bevölkerung für für
freiheit der freiheitseinschränkende
maßnahmen und ich finde das ist dann in
der verantwortung jedes landes in der
jeweiligen situation im rahmen seines
rechtes auch diese entscheidung zu
treffen
für die bundesrepublik kann ich einfach
nur sagen das ist übrigens lage
angemessen ja auch möglich wäre gleich
ganze städte ab regeln aber zumindest
ich habe etliche quarantäne gerade
genannt entsprechende maßnahmen größerem
umfang zu treffen die frage ist da immer
die freiheit ist angemessen und welche
folgen hat es wenn sie einen ort
abriegeln ist die frage was ist mit
denen die schwerst krank sind in dem ort
die jeden tag medikamente brauchen den
arzt sehen müssten sehen sie sie haben
auf einmal dann genau die frage auf was
was bringt das für risiken bezüglich
wirtschaftlich zuerst sondern für die
sicherheit der leute
das müssen sie miteinander abwägen und
aussicht heute jedenfalls glaube ich
dass wir mit den maßnahmen
spectrum dass wir haben und ich habe
gerade ein paar genannt eben auch mit
den dingen dann umgehen können dass
infektionsschutz recht macht jedenfalls
viel möglich herr schule gefahren in der
mitte hat die nächste frage herr sparen
der ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen herr laschet hat
gestern gesagt die lage sei unter
kontrolle übernehmen sie diese wendung
oder würden sie ihnen da korrigieren und
eine andere frage der china gipfel der
eu ratspräsidentschaft deutschlands ist
für september geplant
steht der zeitplan oder halten sie ihm
vor gefährdet zum zeitplan des china
gipfels kann ich ihn jetzt aktuell keine
auskunft geben
ich sehe das eigentlich wie bei der
olympiade das ist jetzt auch zeitlich
noch mit einem solchen fall auch das
glaube ich ist nicht sinn macht das
jetzt im februar schon zu entscheiden
was im juli oder im september ist dann
müssen wir jetzt auch gemeinsam in
dieser dynamischen lage leben und diese
dynamische lage drückt sich auch in dem
haus was gestern passiert ist nordrhein
westfalen das mit dem zeitpunkt wo
ministerpräsident diese aussage
getroffen hat mussten wir auch davon
ausgehen dass die dinge noch unter
kontrolle zu halten sind in dem sinne
dass wir abschließend tatsächlich alle
kontaktpersonen identifizieren konnten
es gab zu dem zeitpunkt wenn ich es
abläufen richtig im kopf hab sogar noch
auf einen konkreten verdacht für die für
den patienten 0 sozusagen für die erste
infektion stelle die er sich dann im
nachhinein in der folge des tages nicht
mehr bestätigt hat also das zeigt aber
eben gestern hat sich über acht stunden
oder zehn stunden im laufe des tages die
lage sehr dynamisch verändert und eine
einschätzung die wir morgens abgeben
kann abends sich schon eben anders
darstellen das muss man immer auch genau
schauen wann
eben eine entsprechende bewertung
abgegeben wird zum zeitpunkt der
bewertung kann das dann eben im
nachhinein oder nichts an nachhinein
später anders anschauen und das finde
ich haben wir gestern miteinander erlebt
und das ist auch das was sie mit
aussagen von mir und seitens der
bundesregierung natürlich natürlich
können sie jetzt eine aussage von mir
aussuchen was ich vor zwei wochen gesagt
hat immer mit der einleitung stand heute
mit dem wissen das ich heute habe mit
der lage wie sie heute ist
wenn man das in diesem gesamtkontext
stellt kann man damit umgehen wir einen
einzelnen satz raus zieht und diesem
gesamtkontext nicht mehr dabei hat das
macht die presse das ist ja das was
gerade in der frage wer welche
verantwortung hat dann schon mal
angedeutet wurden ich habe noch gut zehn
kolleginnen und kollegen auf der liste
sag ich jetzt mal mit blick auf die uhr
und vielleicht mit der bitte um kurze
fragen und antworten herr lange ist der
nächste
ich möchte herr seehofer noch mal kurz
bitte zu dem föderalismus asbeck
nachfragen bei der spar gerade sagte das
ist schon nochmal mit den ländern reden
will
ob man anpassungen ob es anpassungen
braucht das war glaube ich die
formulierung wenn alles vorbei sehen sie
diese notwendigkeit eigentlich auch es
geht ja auch gar nicht vielleicht um
schuldzuweisungen sondern einfach darum
dass man eventuell schneller wird in
dieser ganzen krisenbewältigung und dem
zusammenhang sind die länder eigentlich
im krisenstab vertreten oder nicht ich
sehe es wie jens spahn
weil es meine erfahrung
langweilig dass zehn jahre gesundheit
und landwirtschaft entspricht
es war schwierig sehr spüren dass sie
können nur was ändern mit zustimmung der
länder
das ist auch wahr es geht auch an der
stelle gar nicht darum kompetenzen also
glaube ich wenn man darüber nachdenkt
was man ändert wegzunehmen sozusagen
verschieden zum bund sondern eine
zusätzliche kompetenz zu haben so dass
aber das besprechen wir alles in ruhe
jetzt geht es erstmal darum die
situation wie sie ist und das sage ich
noch mal ausdrücklich damit auch kein
falscher eindruck entsteht es ist eine
sehr sehr gute persönlich wie fachliche
zusammenarbeit zwischen bund und ländern
zwischen den kolleginnen und kollegen
die auch in lagen wie nordrhein
westfalen baden württemberg bayern
hessen rheinland pfalz dann immer auch
sehr konkret mit mir gemeinsam in der
verantwortung sind und dass das klappt
sehr gut dass da will ich gar nicht in
frage stellen
aber wir sind schon gemeinsam mit
manchem gespräch zu dem ergebnis
gekommen dass da weiter
entwicklungsbedarf besteht was die frage
der beteiligung der länder angeht die
werden themen und lagebezogen natürlich
eingebunden
im sonnenland für deutsche verkehrs
zeitung herr seehofer sie sagten eben
sie wollen alle verkehrswege in den
blick nehmen und sagen es gibt halt eben
karten individualreisende ausfüllen
können bei der einreise sieht es denn
aus mit dem güterverkehr also es gibt ja
sehr viel grenzüberschreitenden
lkw-verkehr planen sie da irgendwelche
kontrollen gibt es da auf karten oft
sind es ja auch nicht deutsch sprechende
fahrer und ist immer des krisenstabes
dann muss sie jetzt zurück fahren
staatssekretär zeichnung güterverkehr
gestern beschäftigt ich glaube ich
glaube davon hat jetzt der saal nichts
wenn sie das so in dialog machen
vielleicht muss ich ihn glücklich kann
tatsächlich besteht jederzeit mann aus
dem innenministerium hier sehen wir wie
wir haben das diskutiert aber da sehen
wir natürlich die ansteckungsgefahr
nicht so wie beim personenverkehr in
denen in den gütern sind ja nicht
krankheitserreger in dem maße oder sogar
gar nicht vorhanden wie im
personenverkehr als von daher stellt
sich hier eine ganz andere risiko lagert
aber nachdem man noch nicht alles wissen
behalten wir das bei den blick ja man
muss immer gleich das dazu sagt nicht
entspannt
da gibt es auch morgen noch stimmt ja
wir wissen es nicht hundertprozentig was
über sachen übertragen wird
ich habe noch eine nachfrage besser
bewegen sich ja nicht selbst sondern
werden gefahren von personen und um die
geht es also sind die in irgendeiner
weise und in einer weise in ihrem fokus
dort lagen wir nehmen das als thema
einfach mal vor den morgigen krisenstab
noch mal mit zur nochmaligen betrachtung
ernsthaft und tief
ja das ist natürlich wenn sie wenn sie
da sind berechtigte freibad natürlich
herzlichen nächste frage was ist mit dem
individualverkehr
es waren noch jeden tag weiß garnicht
millionen autos wahrscheinlich über über
die jeweiligen grenzen so und dann ist
eine frage was ist verhältnismäßig was
ist händelbar nur sind maßnahmen zu
ergreifen die wir tatsächlich auch
umsetzen können
und all diese themen dafür aber den
krisenstab eingerichtet
jedenfalls dessen dass wir nicht dass
der eindruck entsteht wir reden ja seit
heute miteinander gehen sollte der
kontakte die es zwischen den häusern
auch schon den letzten wochen gab aber
jetzt eben noch
anders institutionalisiert die dann in
besprochen werden dann hatte die
kollegen direkt dahinter auch eine frage
des mini christopher bailey aus den usa
sie haben es teilweise schon beantwortet
und ich habe es nicht so ganz verstanden
am inwieweit halten sie dann die
eventuelle abregelung von städten so wie
wir das in china gesehen haben für
sinnvoll oder überhaupt möglichen wie
weit ist das denn möglich und ist das
eine frage des bundes oder eine frage
der verschiedenen ländern und städten
die entscheidung ist eine entscheidung
der länder und der behörden vor ort
sie ist rechtlich möglich in auslegung
des infektionsschutzgesetzes aber aus
unserer sicht stand heute ist normal aus
unserer sicht stand heute nicht
notwendig keine frage ein seehofer ich
war überrascht dass die asylbewerber
eigens genannt haben nach meinem wissen
ist er die balkanroute überhaupt keinen
schwerpunkt von corona norditalien
natürlich schon
inwieweit ist der aufenthaltsstatus
überhaupt relevant für ansteckung und
müsste es nicht so sein dass diese leute
genauso wie alle anderen möglicherweise
bei einem verdacht beim grenzübertritt
in geprüft oder getestet werden
[Musik]
also die gesundheitsuntersuchung gehört
er heute zum standard bei bekannten und
jetzt wird dieser standard erweitert um
den test und befundung bei kronach wie
aus ich finde dass ein mensch der
untersucht wird auf tuberkulose
wird jetzt eben auch auf diesem punkt
untersucht und ich sagte ja eingangs
wenn sie auf die hauptherkunftsländer
schauen afghanistan iran etc
dann dürfen sie nicht nur die westbalkan
gute sehen sollen die menschen
durchqueren diese länder oder kommen aus
diesen ländern
wenn sie hier nach deutschland oder nach
europa einreisen und deshalb auch wenn
sie die ganze transitstrecke mit
betrachten ist dies notwendig übrigens
auch zum schutz dass wir in unsere
gemeinschaftsunterkünfte des virus nach
möglichkeit oder den eintrag des virus
vermeiden
eine andere frage ist wenn hier
erkrankungen in nennenswerter zahl bei
der beförderung festgestellt werden
sollten auch das habe ich gesagt müssen
wir gemeinsam mit den ländern auch
überlegen ob wir die dann in quarantäne
einrichtungen sozusagen unterbringen um
die das vortragen des virus zu vermeiden
das auch nicht ganz einfach trotzdem
muss man sich konzeptionell damit
beschäftigen es wieder eine aufgabe des
krisenstabes
weil sie müssen ja dann karten bilden
sie können einfach in ein haus alle die
die letzten vier wochen untersucht
worden sind und einen verdacht haben
unterbringen sondern sie müssen ja im
hinblick auf die inkubationszeit sagen
die menschen sind jetzt schon zwei
wochen in diesem gebäude
die andere sind erst zwei tage da und es
ist auch logistisch keine ganz einfache
aufgabe
wenn das in größerem umfang erfolgt
müssen wir uns über diese unterbringung
unterhalten
wir können sie nicht dann einfach in
ganz deutschland haben schlüssel
verteilen wie das heute der fall ist
obwohl wir denn die erkenntnis haben da
ist der verdacht oder sogar der ausbruch
der krankheit dar
dann kann man nicht mehr sagen wenn die
bayern kommen jetzt verteilen wir zehn
prozent davon nach niedersachsen
sondern dann ist man schon überlegen
gemeinsam mit den ländern das ist eine
ganz wichtige schnittstelle in dem punkt
aber glaube ich das kriegen wir auch
gemeinsam hin sei auch im interesse der
länder
niemand hat ein interesse ineinander
zentrum in eine ankunft unterricht
einrichtung dieses virus einzutragen
deshalb ist es jetzt keine besondere
asyl diskussion sondern eine
notwendigkeit ich sagte noch bei 10.000
im monat
und die kommen aus diesen regionen
sie sagen 10.000 monat wenn das mit man
das mit der zahl von geschäftsleuten
vergleicht die jeden tag in die ganze
welt fliegen weiß ich nicht ob diese
gruppe zu einer außerordentliche
gesteigerte aufmerksamkeit verdient die
gesundheitsversorgung die in den
vorangegangenen wochen stattgefunden hat
dürfte schon eine höchst
unterschiedliche seien die frage welches
kontaktes zum gesundheitswesen gegeben
hat auf der rote kontakt zu anderen
es gibt nicht ohne grund deswegen bin
ich auch horst seehofer sehr dankbar
dass das in den anker zentren und in
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen auch gemacht
wird mit den ländern
gesundheitsuntersuchungen es wird bei
jedem eine gesundheitsuntersuchung
gemacht in dem entsprechenden verfahren
mit blick auch auf andere übertragbare
krankheiten im übrigen und das ist eine
dann von mehreren untersuchungen
insofern finde ich muss man es da
entsprechend einordnen noch nicht so wie
sie ist möglicherweise einordnen großer
wunsch der bevölkerung das weiß ich aus
den ganzen letzten jahren dass die
bevölkerung erwartet das schwierigere
erkrankungen da nicht schleichend
einwandern gerade tuberkulose war bei
uns in münchen ein ganz großes thema aus
ländern mit mangelversorgung mit
mangelernährung ist ja sowas immer sehr
stark zu befürchten und
ich glaube sie stellen seien gegensatz
her der in der praxis nicht fahren
ich glaube dass unsere pflicht wenn
jemand einreisten schutz begehrt dass
man dies rechtsstaatlich prüft ob der
schutz begehren berechtigt ist und
gleichzeitig sicherstellt dass
schwierige und gefährliche erkrankungen
nicht über diese wege nach deutschland
kommen müssen wir machen
nächste frage hat die kollegen fläche
von fabienne eckert vom deutschen
ärzteblatt herr spahn
welche aufgaben werden sie denn an die
kv und die kammern und jahren
krisenstäbe delegieren
ich habe sie gebeten aufgefordert wie
sie es formulieren wollen aber es war
auch in großem einvernehmen es jetzt
nicht so dass ich dass wir irgendwie
gegenseitig jetzt überzeugen mussten
solle im gegenseitigen einvernehmen
nochmal das was sowieso schon da war
also ich weiß auch nicht sein dass sie
erst gestern angefangen haben sondern
dass wir gemeinsam in dem bewusstsein
dass manche information mehrfach
rübergebracht werden müssen bis sie eine
so große zahl von adressaten erreichen
und ja auch immer in einer geänderten
lage dass die kassenärztlichen
vereinigung und die ärztekammer neben
sich bereit erklärt haben nochmal und
nicht nur einmal sondern mehrfach die
mitglieder die ärztin und ersten zu
informieren ich habe dazu eine kleine
nachfrage wie woher bekommen denn die
ärzte zum beispiel gedruckten
informationsmaterialien poster flyer
müssen sie sich die bestellen bekommen
sie die automatisch zugesandt von den kv
zum beispiel den kammern
es gibt angebote da auch der
bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung ist robert koch instituts
aber wir wollen auch sicherstellen dass
das im zweifel einfach per e-mail pdf
dann auch entsprechend die kolleginnen
und kollegen über die ärztinnen und
ärzte erreicht dass die nächste frage
herr wie schon mal ein
die in der nächsten woche ist auch eine
plenarwoche im bundestag da kommen
mehrere hundert leute zusammen mit einem
extrem aktiven sozialleben hoffentlich
können sie sagen ob diese sache so
stattfindet oder wäre das etwas was man
vielleicht sagen du bist dafür zuständig
[Gelächter]
also grundsätzlich das ist das was wir
gerade gesagt haben können kriterien
liefern das frage ist der
teilnehmerkreis zu wem hat der
teilnehmerkreis vorher kontakt aus
welchen ländern kann der wird wie wird
und interagiert und ich sage jetzt mal
ein kollege ja gerade weiß ich nicht in
china in norditalien in südkorea auf
dienstreise oder privat unterwegs war
er muss genauso wie die mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter übrigen auch alle
journalistischen kollegen die im zweifel
auf reisen sagen wie jeder bürger der
auf reisen war oder kontakt hat der
mitreisenden eben auch ein bewusstsein
haben das ist etwas was ich vermute ja
auch auf allen kanälen zu vermitteln
ja wir haben eine verantwortung und die
wollen wir auch wahrnehmen entschieden
wahrnehmen dafür der krisenstab aber es
hat eben jeder auch eine
mitverantwortung oder eine mithilfe
möglichkeit und das gilt für abgeordnete
des deutschen bundestages genauso wie
für jeden anderen bürger dieses landes
auch je nachdem wo man sich aufgehalten
hat in den letzten tagen entsprechend
dann mit anderen umzugehen vorsichtig zu
sein und die technischen
verhaltensmaßnahmen die gelten sowieso
glaube ich für menschen die so viel
soziale kontakte haben wie sie und wir
und viele andere hände waschen
aufmerksam sein nicht ins gesicht fassen
so viel klingt banal macht aber ein
unterschied also sich selbst vielleicht
ganz kurz danach
es ist echt wichtig wenn sie einfach mal
drauf achten wir auf dem tag man sich
selbst ins gesicht fasst und damit eben
auch infektionsrisiko entsteht dann
meine ich das sehr sehr ernst
auch ernste nachfrage der nationale
volkskongress in china dr
etwas größer sei als der bundestag der
wurde verschoben so was ist aber noch
nicht in planung
nein weil auch schlicht und ergreifend
das infektionsgeschehen in china auch
ein anderes ist also müssen wir schon
auch da wieder verhältnismäßig bleiben
wenn sie schauen was und china sich
entwickelt hat den letzten wochen und
wie die lage in deutschland europa ist
dann sehe ich da schon noch unterschiede
an sie habe in meiner heimatstadt
ingolstadt in china zentrum
das liegt an der verbindung von audi mit
china da stellt sich die problematik
wieder völlig anders da weil es da
ständigen austausch gibt zwischen china
und bayern da muss man auch in der
aufklärung eingehen und die leute
unmittelbar versuchen zu erreichen
die werden nicht dass die lektüre einer
zeitung ausreichend sensibilisiert
werden können
so muss man immer von fall zu fall von
betrieb zu betrieb von einrichtungen zur
einrichtung die dinge verantwortlich
entscheiden
nach heutigem erkenntnisstand sage ich
ausdrücklich dazu wir werden versuchen
noch die letzten fünf fragen kurz zu
machen
das schaffen wir das noch dann als
nächstes herr zweigner dann ja sehen wo
ich möchte ganz normal zu den
großveranstaltungen von nachfragen wann
halten sie es denn für sinnvoll und
notwendig dass man so etwas ab sagt ich
habe jetzt mal nehmen jetzt meinen blick
die champions league ist ja durchaus
vorstellbar dass mannschaften aus
italien dass wir wenn du dich reden
beispielsweise demnächst in leipzig
münchen dortmund spielt und umgekehrt
und das sind jeweils tausende fans
unterwegs
wer soll denn da entscheiden also das
event in italien spielen können sie ja
schlecht allerdings kann ja in
deutschland würde nicht sagen ihr dürft
doch nicht spielen und die fans nicht
daran dorthin zu fahren und so noch mal
die geistige grundlage ist
auch dem einmaleins der infektions
bekämpfung nico können wir vermeiden
den eintrag des virus nach deutschland
mit respektive maßnahmen jetzt haben wir
die ausstiegs karte oder das einstellen
des migranten austausches zwischen
italien und deutschland bei
großveranstaltungen haben wir gebeten
dass die der krisenstab sich morgen
damit beschäftigt ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass der krisenstab kriterien
entwickelt die für diejenigen die
großveranstaltungen durchführen
ein prüfungsmaßstab sind wir haben heute
mal im persönlichen gespräch so
entwickelt es kommt darauf an aus
welchen ländern die menschen da in
erster linie kommen oder aus welchen
regionen wo das virus besonders
ausgeprägt aufgetreten ist
das glaube ich diese mühe müssten wir
schon unterziehen
über diese sache freilich nur ergänzen
darf wie einsichtig ist ein organisator
einer veranstaltung was abläufe angeht
ist jemand bereit informationsmaterial
flyer desinfektionsmittel hygiene
auflagen zu machen wo dass er nicht
bereit ist glaube ich auch ein parameter
für die frage ob man sagt kann
stattfinden oder kann nicht stattfinden
und wenn du sagst fc ingolstadt und
geister
also ich glaube die spiele noch nicht
eine obere europaweiten entschuldigen
wollen sie der bundesliga gespielt
gespielt haben
nein aber ein kreisspiel kreisligaspiel
in heinsberg ist anders im moment zu
bewerten als ein kreisligaspiel in
schleswig holstein so das muss man
natürlich auch einfach von den
gegebenheiten in der jeweiligen region
in dem jeweiligen geschehen abhängig
machen und dies wird jetzt ein champions
league spiel geben wenn ich richtig
informiert bin turin mailand das ohne
zuschauer statt findet weil sie eben
eine entscheidung der behörde im
einzelfall gewesen ist vor ort weil
mailand eben involviert der regierung
begründet
also das kann man schon beherrschen und
da setze ich sehr auf den krisenstab
morgen herr minister eine nachfrage zu
den speziellen atemschutzmasken die sie
angesprochen hatten haben sie eine
vorstellung davon wie viel überhaupt nur
im land sind und ob die nicht längst zum
größten teil in china verwendet werden
und die andere frage zur vorstellung der
behördlichen vernetzung sie machen jetzt
im moment nicht jeden tag ein krisenstab
kann man sich vorstellen dass er
irgendwann in permanenz tagen wird sie
sagen bei bedarf werden die länder mit
hineingenommen ich kann mir vorstellen
man kommt von der einen frage im
krisenstab plötzlich zudem bedarf den
sie gesehen haben wie läuft da die
vernetzung zwischen dem städtischen
gesundheitsamt und dem
bundesgesundheitsministerium also erster
teil die zahl der schutzausrüstung
masken im land kann ich ihnen
abschließend der es wenig sagen weil
vieles eben in privater hand ist ein
großhandel bei herstellern apotheken
möglicherweise wo wir jetzt auch noch
mal mit den verbänden
schon gespräche begonnen haben
weiterführen wollen was ich viel
wichtiger finde ist wie wir
sicherstellen und auch darüber ist
morgen im krisenstab zu sprechen
das ist im land bleibt dass wir also
nicht noch irgendwie sehen dass es in
andere länder geht sondern möglichst
viel von dem was noch im land ist
tatsächlich auch im land bleibt auch
wenn es in privatrechtlicher hand ist
das halte ich für sehr sehr wichtig ein
zweiter teil
sie dürfen jetzt nicht den eindruck
haben dass wir jetzt heute anfangen
miteinander zu reden
es gibt die idee wie sie heißt die
arbeitsgruppe infektionsschutz heißt ich
glaube ich der länder mit dem bund im
robert-koch-institut die haben manchmal
täglich wenn es bedarf gibt zwei oder
drei trikots telefonkonferenz
miteinander zumindest mal immer
lageabhängig sie haben regulär jede
woche regelmäßig abstimmung miteinander
das robert koch institut koordiniert
nach einer entscheidung der länder die
wir bei geführt haben nachdem
infektionsschutz recht auch wie viel
stärker seit einigen wochen dieses
zusammenspiel mit den ländern also es
gibt ja jenseits des minister
austausches richtigerweise auf allen
ebenen einen intensiven austausch zu den
unterschiedlichen fragen es gilt ja auch
für die ressorts
wir haben auch in jeder lage wenn es um
die uhr an rückkehrer ging wenn es um
andere maßnahmen geht immer dann in
verschiedenen ressort zusammensetzung
und kreisen natürlich auch innerhalb der
bundesregierung auf allen ebenen
miteinander miteinander gesprochen also
der eindruck wir fangen jetzt erst
morgen an uns zu vernetzen wäre falsch
was neu ist ist ebenso zu sagen die
institutionalisieren die wir jetzt mit
diesem krisenstab haben wir im
pandemieplan auch vorgesehen ist er hat
nach dem pandemieplan der übrigens kein
geheim werk ist und der pandemieplan ist
eben auch ja öffentlich verfügbar
die entsprechenden aufgaben des
krisenstabes und da werden jetzt auch
regelhaft andere ressorts beteiligt und
dann immer lageabhängig eben alle
anderen die man für die jeweiligen
themen
dann braucht es gibt übrigens in der
folge auch die möglichkeit noch weitere
register zu ziehen was die einbindung
formal der länder angeht
in der weiteren entwicklung also wir
haben natürlich je nach lage noch die
möglichkeit institutionalisiert im
rahmen des pandemie
plans weitere schritte zu gehen frau
wolff ich habe nochmal einen nachfrage
nach speziellen personellen kapazitäten
in krankenhäusern sie sparen vor offen
krankenhausbetten die kann auch
provisorisch erweitert werden bei
personellen kapazitäten ist das
schwieriger sehen sie da auch die länder
in der pflicht oder wie wollen sie
darauf reagieren und noch eine frage an
herrn seehofer am der ausbruch in china
hat ja zu einer deutlichen zunahme an
diskriminierungs fällen gegenüber
chinesen oder menschen aus ostasien
geführt das hat die un hochkommissarin
für menschenrechte jetzt mittlerweile
schon auch dazu veranlasst eine stärkere
bemühungen gegen diese
diskriminierungsfälle zuvor dann wählen
die diese gefahr dass das zunimmt und
jetzt auch speziell weil sie meinen für
die testungen von zuwanderern über
problemregionen werden ausgeweitet
werden sie diese gefahren wie sollte man
aus ihrer sicht darauf reagiert zuerst
nicht dafür hände waren noch ergänzen
wir haben bei der
krankenhausgesellschaft die
informationen vorliegen gehabt schon ich
hatte sie noch nicht präsent 28.000
intensivbetten gibt es in deutschland
was die frage angeht der personellen
kapazitäten ist das ja auch das was in
den pandemie planung der häuser der
krankenhäuser der pflegeeinrichtung zu
sehen ist und bin wenn jetzt immer unter
der prämisse wie sich die lage weiter
entwickelt wie eine situation haben
sollten mit deutlich mehr infektionen in
deutschland und dann daraus resultierend
eben auch schwerere verläufe und bedarf
nach isolierung baten um intensivpflege
für einzelne patienten dann kommen wir
halt in eine ausnahme situation kämen
wir rein die natürlich dann ist
erfordert dann auch tatsächlich
entsprechend personalplanung zu machen
geplante operationen geplante maßnahmen
zu verschieben ressourcen zu
konzentrieren auf das was jetzt
notwendig ist möglicherweise wird es
auch nicht gehen ohne die bereitschaft
daneben auch mehr stunden zu machen und
anderes mehr
natürlich würde eine entsprechende lage
wenn sie sich so entwickelt ich zeige
jetzt so das szenario weil sie fragen
was wäre wenn eine wo dann alle
beteiligten auch diejenigen ärzte
pflegekräfte die anderen leben
gesundheitswesen arbeiten daneben auch
in einer ausnahmesituation gefordert
werden dass es keinen normalbetrieb mehr
möglich dann oder man würde bestimmte
zentrale krankenhäuser identifizieren
die sich gezielt in einer region darum
kümmern und daraufhin die abläufe
steuern
das sind aber eben auch alles dinge die
in den pandemieplänen der länder und der
krankenhäuser vorgesehen sind deswegen
finde ich sind so wichtig soweit noch
nicht geschehen ich weiß dass viele
schon haben aber spätestens jetzt
sollten die die noch nicht haben sich
eben genau mit diesen fragen in planung
geschäft für den fall der fälle zu
unserer oberster grundsatz ist der
gesundheitsschutz der auch das sollten
wir ja vorkommen die zelle interessen
hier
deshalb wollen wir die leute
diskriminieren sondern ihnen helfen und
die untersuchung und erich sprach die
hat irgendwie auch bedeutung für
chinesen die in deutschland zunehmend
asyl beantragen hilft den betroffenen
für den fall einer infektion frühzeitig
in richtige gesundheitliche versorgung
zukommen und schützt gleichzeitig die
bevölkerung vor den bios und was in
china abläuft möchte ich jetzt hier
nicht beurteilen wenn die
hochkommissarin das tut ist ihr gutes
recht aber ich kann ihnen jetzt nur
erläutern welche philosophie wir
vertreten
dieser menschen hilft die diese
behandlung kurzer nachfrage kurze
nachfrage ich wollte in dieser frage
auch nicht in unterstellen dass sie mit
diesen testungen diskriminierung
betreiben aber faktisch haben wir das
rettungs fälle zugenommen beispielsweise
menschen aus china oder ostasien also
die frage ist wie geht man mit dieser
form der diskriminierung
deswegen ist finde ich übrigens ja so
wichtig dass wir diese tests damit ja
auch sagen können wir können so weit es
geht eben mit den angeboten die wir
haben entsprechend sicherstellen oder
reduzieren einen denn das entsprechende
infektionen gibt und gleichzeitig sieht
man die ganze und das ist ja die aufgabe
die ich sage es noch einmal möchte das
hier darf in der bundespressekonferenz
die wir gemeinsam haben
in der frage wie wir informieren wenn
asiatisch stämmigen bürgerinnen und
bürger beschreiben was sie erleben im
alltag zum teil an reaktionen aus
unsicherheit heraus aber keine
unsicherheit der welt rechtfertigt das
was teilweise an diskriminierung
berichtet wird auch hier in deutschland
und da haben wir gemeinsame
verantwortung eben auch was das
einordnen angeht von risiken von der
frage was im persönlichen verhältnis für
risiken bestehen aber auch ganz
grundsätzlich dass dann eben tatsächlich
solche irrationalitäten nicht nicht
entstehen ich meine sie kennen die
geschichte von dem webasto mitarbeitern
die einen ganz anderen werken als das
betroffene auf einmal ihre autos nicht
mehr in der kfz werkstatt haben
reparieren lassen können weil die sorge
da war man steckt sich sozusagen durch
die rapperin dem auto möglicherweise
während sind soldaten die mir in
germersheim beschreiben als während die
zentrale unterbringung war dass wenn sie
mit bargeld gezahlt haben
die teilweise die scheine anschließend
desinfiziert wurden
das eben alles nur zeitlich beschreibt
das jetzt nur anekdotenhaft welche
unsicherheit im umgang mit diesem
unbekannten virus da ist und wir haben
die gemeinsame verantwortung dass aus
dieser unsicherheit nicht derartige in
akzeptable reaktion resultieren wie sie
beschrieben haben und die wir eben auch
ich habe das signal bekommen dass wir
tatsächlich jetzt zum ende kommen müssen
weil die minister wahrscheinlich noch
andere termine haben wenn ich sie
richtig verstanden hat der spanier und
die nächste woche wieder damit experten
da freuen wir uns drauf danke ihnen fürs
kommen danke liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und bleiben sie gesund
franken